meghan trainor diplo collaboration could
be in the works
I just saw you talking with Diplo down
there you were you were whispering
something into each other's ears
is this how collaborations began every
time I'm like yeah we produce this one
song is like yeah it's just you don't
text me you don't call me you don't send
me the songs he's like every time I see
it award shows then you ask me I'm like
I I'm gonna text everyone yeah we set it
on a table with talked about it before
I see her everywhere actually she's
another person who loves to collaborate
is that energy and in collaborating you
really love that or you like to do stuff
on your own or next lot of people with a
great with a big personality you know
that can have an opinion and have strong
opinions in the studio and make me do
things I don't you know I'm mom will
comfortable with it I think that she's
similar they're really strong personally
I love her voice I love her attitude but
there's another big artist Megan tells
et she'd love to work with as an artist
artists like visually Beyonce kills it
in her shows and I want to do some cool
stuff like that I'm gonna get a meghan
trainor beyonce collaboration can you
imagine my dream is when that's been
happening but I don't know I I met her
and she's so lovely and I hope one day
we could work